my administration has been guided by
that idea that's why we stopped
defending the so-called Defense of
Marriage Act and why we were pleased
when the court finally struck down a
central provision of that discriminatory
law it's why we ended Don't Ask Don't
Tell from extending full marital
benefits to federal employees and their
spouses to expanding hospital visitation
rights for LGBT patients and their loved
ones we've made real progress in
advancing equality for LGBT Americans in
ways that were unimaginable not too long
ago I no change for many of our LGBT
brothers and sisters must have seemed so
slow for so long but compared to so many
other issues America's shift has been so
quick I know that Americans of good will
continue to hold a wide range of views
on this issue Opposition in some cases
has been based on sincere and deeply
held beliefs all of us who welcome
today's news should be mindful of that
fact recognize different viewpoints
Revere our deep commitment to religious
freedom but today should also give us
hope that on the many issues with which
we grapple often painfully real change
is possible shifts in hearts and minds
is possible
are on their journey to cual they have a
responsibility to reach back and help
others join them because for all our
differences we are one people stronger
together than we could ever be alone
that's always been our story we are big
and vast and diverse a nation of people
with different backgrounds and beliefs
different experiences and stories but
bound by our shared ideal that no matter
who you are or what you look like how
you started off or how and who you love
America is a place where you can write
your own destiny we are people who
believe that every single child is
entitled to life and liberty and the
pursuit of happiness there's so much
more work to be done to extend the full
promise of America every American but
today we can say in no uncertain terms
that we've made our union a little more
perfect that's the consequence of a
decision on the Supreme Court but more
importantly it is a consequence of the
countless small acts of courage of
millions of people across decades
who stood up who came out talked to
parents
parents who loved their children no
matter what folks who were willing to
endure bullying and taunts and stayed
strong
and came to believe in themselves and
who they were and slowly made an entire
country realize that love is love what
an extraordinary achievement but what a
vindication of the belief that ordinary
people can do extraordinary things what
a reminder of what Bobby Kennedy once
said about how small actions can be like
pebbles being thrown into still like
ripples of hope cascade outwards and
change the world
those countless often anonymous heroes
they deserve our thanks they should be
very proud America should be very proud
thank you % Obama they're speaking about
the historic Supreme Court ruling that
says same-sex couples have the right to
marry in all 50 US states calling this a
victory for America and a big step in
our march towards equality